in a province that takes pride in
putting strangers at ease this plane
load of new arrivals lands right in
newfoundland and labrador's comfort zone
premier andrew fury greeting the first
of 166 passengers angelica as onlookers
send their own messages of support
after fleeing the devastating russian
invasion coming to a canadian province
whose rugged beauty helps offset its
tenuous finances is a huge relief stan
has a job in favor welcome stan who's
headed to bay chamber
stan is a mining engineer he says his
father is still in central ukraine but
urged him to leave but
i very worried about my father he's
nominal and
he will just told me that
as i'm in this war you have your chance
for your future this first of its kind
airlift cost an estimated three hundred
fifty thousand dollars including on the
ground logistics it's a reward on
another investment almost two months ago
when the province opened an office in
poland to help ukrainians relocate
sorting out things like travel documents
and transportation plans as other
provinces ramp up their support the
federal government is promising to move
ahead with its own plans for targeted
charter flights the feds say they've
received more than 204 000 applications
from ukrainians approving more than 91
000 and that more than 24 000 have
arrived in canada since january first
arriving ukrainians have been granted an
emergency travel visa that allows them
to live and work in canada for three
years and the newfoundland and labrador
government says they'll get provincial
medicare and prescription drug coverage
other challenges could take time like
nurturing this seven-year-old girl who
doesn't speak english
with hundreds of other ukrainians
applying to fly here these arrivals
might be only the beginning of this
small province's big relief effort ross
lord global news